hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action unleashes We are
continuing with our one game per day and
uh well uh hoping to improve and to give
you guys some uh some fundamentals on
how to how to play a game of chess now
as as I said in the previous video uh
these games will definitely not be on
the level of the games that I usually
cover from Top Grand Masters they will
be more of a you know sometimes I miss
something sometimes my opponent misses
something and then who gets the uh take
advantage of that mistake so let's check
it out uh some of you suggested maybe I
should um Kick It Up to 15 minutes per
player maybe it will give me more time
to discuss positions but um no I'm still
feeling very comfortable with 10 minutes
so if I if I need I'm going to uh do it
so okay so E4 I said in the previous
video that I'm going to give it a bit of
a pause with the Scandinavian so I'm
going to stick with the Sicilian Defense
and uh depending on what my opponent
plays I will be playing the hyper
accelerated dragon
uh sort of a fun way to to play the
Sicilian where you don't need to learn
like everything you don't need to know
the Knight of the the havening the
classical Sicilian you just the hyper
accelerated Dragon there are maybe three
lines and that's that's what you
play uh of course yeah our opponent just
left uh we can we can actually claim
victory in 70 seconds but we will not do
that um we
will uh draw okay I can't even draw I
have to wait okay that's that's a bit
sad uh so maybe he comes back can I
abort
no yeah I can't even
abort okay
so uh yeah probably next game we will
also be getting the black pieces since I
don't think you get um uh like a oh no
he came back okay so as this is for the
purposes of making a video we're going
to going to give him his time back there
we go more time there you go all
right oh no
he he didn't want to
play okay so we're going to go for
another
opponent yeah we got the black pieces
again uh as we were expecting that okay
so D4 for this one uh so we're going to
shift it to Knight F6 our opponent for
this game is Mr tgl or Mrs tgl or uh and
he goes for C4 okay so here everything
possibly you go for the Catlin for the
nimzo for the uh well all all sorts of
interesting ideas um for the ANTM okay
so he invites me for an NSO Indian and I
like to play that so I will go for it
Bishop to B4 and um now okay so Queen to
C2 this is I don't know what's it called
like the classical line or the
traditional line no I think E3 is the
traditional this is the classical I
don't know what's the difference in the
words traditional and classical and they
pretty much look the same uh but yeah
we're going to go uh with the standard
stuff so
D5 um probably capture B6 Bishop A6
those are some of the moves I want to
play and we'll see if I can play them in
in any meaningful
order um okay so he
captures uh capturing with the Knight
seems like a nice idea but uh when you
capture with a pawn now you really don't
have to worry about how to develop your
light Square Bishop now can develop it
pretty much
anyway uh I'm not familiar with with
this line in particular but I'm pretty
sure I could even develop it this way as
I I'm going to win a Tempo at some
point uh but yeah it's very
interesting uh so let's just Castle here
castling in the nimzo is like the fourth
move you want to play sometimes fifth
you can never go wrong with castling in
the
nzo um yeah we'll go
C5 hoping to to put more pressure on the
white king here as it's still in the
center of the
board yeah now he can't really allow
captures captures would be pretty bad
for
him or maybe he can I don't know uh not
not an expert on on this line or any
line for that matter so we're just going
to play some moves that uh seem like
they should be played and these are all
moves that kind of should be played like
this grabs more space this grabs more
space this put pressure on the center uh
the bishop here very deep in your
opponent's position now of course Rook
to E1 Rook d8 is a move you want to play
okay so he go he he puts pressure on my
H7 Pawn uh which is um interesting but I
don't think uh it's interesting enough
for me to actually react to it like C
captures on D4
uh I still think that's um the way to go
he he can capture
sure he can
capture um yeah I don't think it's
possible I I I think the Central Pawn
could be more important than the H7 Pawn
here so he'll probably uh either he will
go for it I don't know if that was his
idea yeah he's just going to capture
back he's not he's not
crazy and
now um yeah okay so now we we can unpin
that's for sure because it puts pressure
on this pawn and it also guards our
Knight here but then he can just capture
for example and and take the H7 Pawn uh
but do I mind him capturing the H7
Pawn is that something that I should be
worried about not really he will have to
waste a move move once he captures I
play King h8 he will have to move it
back otherwise I'm just going to trap it
with um with a move like
G6 and he might run into some trouble so
yeah we'll go
for um does one check do anything for me
not
really yeah let's go um let's go Queen
B6
so he probably captures and captures on
H7 and then just brings the bishop back
and he he is convinced that he will be
able to
survive with that pawn grab all right
let's see it let's see it the
done or he might just ignore me
completely and just continue
development we'll see we'll see what he
does uh but yeah if if he captures I
capture yeah Bishop captures I move the
sorry Bishop captures I move the king
not a problem he has to move yeah he's
just going to continue developing and
defend his Pawn as he should and now now
we can
actually maybe maybe we can become a
little bit annoying
here again I could offer a pawn with
something like Knight D4 he could
take and what then
what do we do
then yeah not the best not the
best
H yeah okay here I I kind of have to
play H6 I don't think I have
uh I tried to make it
as last as long as possible but yeah I
have to play H6 now
unfortunately
oh he will capture uh yeah I did not
expect the capture there definitely did
not expect that uh and I will have to
worry about my Pawn here a little bit uh
but only only a little bit I I believe
yeah now I do have the bishop pair for
the
moment uh if I can put some pressure uh
to his King side that's also going to be
great so we can just continue
development
yeah uh I feel like he got uh way less
out of um out of playing against the
nimzo than he should
have but we'll see we're going to
analyze it afterwards with the engine
and and see what what's what
uh but yeah maybe spending a little bit
too much time here okay so he goes for
the pawn and wants me
to yeah he wants me to either give up
the
pawn what do we have
here yeah now it's time
to
now it's time to threaten
some nasty
ideas um yeah even Queen captures here
is an option
but I don't think it gives you all that
much maybe it does no he he will take
that yeah I thought maybe capturing on
B7 was a little bit better since I can
play Knight to C6 I would have to go to
D7 uh but yeah okay this is
fine this is fine okay so here G3 if I
go H3 he does have this Knight a very
annoying move here but no he doesn't I
can just capture he can't capture as
this is a problem
so uh will be interesting will be very
interesting
okay so he just blundered mate I have no
idea why he did
that
yeah uh but okay this was a pretty short
one so we're going to play another one
let me just check
uh why uh if it was okay in general yeah
so okay this is perfectly fine perfectly
fine perfectly
fine yeah Bishop
D3 capture see okay it's the B to
capture on H 7 H6 yeah okay everything
is fine Queen captures it's all 0 0 0 0
so nothing spectacular here yeah Knight
captures okay Queen yeah we have to play
G okay so so pretty much uh everything
was fine the the pawn sacrifice that I
made was maybe a little ambitious but I
mean nothing spectacular yeah play
G3 and the game continues but okay uh
since we did not expect our opponent to
uh well go down this easily we will play
another one as this was fairly fairly
quickly uh
concluded all right so we got the white
pieces now and we'll see what our
opponent plays okay so it's a sicilian
our opponent is Mr Killer
777 Triple 7 killer and he goes for
Knight to C6 and here okay since this is
for recording purposes I should play uh
the the standard stuff but against
Knight to C6 I exclusively play B4
uh doesn't matter the time format it's
just um sort of like uh another way you
can play the Evans Gambit um uh against
something else than the Joko piano so
okay he goes D5 I'm going to capture and
play C4 simply to get a lot of Rapid
development
in uh because it's it's also such a such
a fun line now he has to play this if he
doesn't play this he's just
lost
um not sure how yeah that's not that's
not good that's pretty
bad yeah it's pretty
bad
um yeah let's go D5 I
mean I know he he shouldn't be able to
play like this I just don't know the the
precise reason why but it's a very
tricky line we can even give one check
here simply to Castle to save
safety and uh yeah he will have some
issues developing now like uh how do you
develop yeah okay you can play that
but uh probably some G6
moves um yeah let's go Rook e one so
sort of to stop G6 because now if G6 D6
could be very
strong he's not afraid of anything he's
just playing
he's just playing moves
here that's really really
nice yeah how do you how do you develop
here probably there's a way
like maybe Queen A5 now he does put
pressure on a lot of stuff here but I
don't I I still don't think even that is
enough I think I think it's just uh I
think it's just busted
here yeah okay so he will try that to to
buy some
time um and we have to figure out the
cleanest way to to end
this how how do we end this in the
cleanest way
possible
yeah I could I could just take and then
if he takes I could even capture here
Bishop captures and play D6 but then he
can just no he can't even Castle I feel
like uh I I can do that I just don't
think uh I have to I think my position
is sort of even better than that I don't
need to rush
anything yeah but we're going to capture
here and play Queen
D4 now that's sort of
gets him out of the woods
maybe
oh I mean I I really don't see why this
wouldn't be winning
so very hard not to play
it yeah he really he really had to
decide which side to go
to and now he either does something and
I capture with the pawn or I can even
capture with the Rook so he can't
Castle so if he castles or if he doesn't
Castle he's not going to be castling
that's uh that's pretty
good it's probably just going to play a
developing move like Rook to C8 and then
we
continue no he's going to play it like
this
okay so yeah that's pretty pretty
interesting it's pretty
interesting so while while this looks
very
forcing there's no need to actually Rush
that or is there
huh very interesting yeah now he's
actually threatening the castle maybe if
I just play Nothing we'll just
take I don't want to overthink it then
and spend too much time on
this we'll do this probably he will go
here be no he
won't very
interesting Okay so
now he wants to go
here
obviously he wants to obviously go
here so we will wait him wait for him
there there we
go be very very
annoying
yeah very very interesting
stuff so he has to move the king
although I mean it doesn't look like a
great Square for the king
and he doesn't have a a good way of U of
trading down
material yeah he could go for some nah I
don't have like a particular threat here
which is which is sad as I I I I think
my position is so great I should be
having all sorts of threats okay so he
plays this for some reason I have no
idea why he played that yeah that that
just looks like a weird
move
uh
ah okay yeah of of course he just wanted
to defend that so I
can uh so I can't do this but
uh yeah it does look like a like a
rather passive
Square okay so what's the what's the
cleanest way we have five minutes we we
don't have to rush
anything we probably getting the other
Rook into the game is the way to
go uh we could also get the Knight into
the the game that's possible since this
Knight cannot
move but what to do with the Knight
after after we go there that's the
question yeah the Knight could go here
and then King G7 does appear to be the
move so let's just play Rook
B1
play Rook B1 uh he can't really defend
that and if he moves the pawn then his
Queen no longer covers any of the
squares on the fifth rank uh I do have
to be a little bit careful due to my
back rank issues like if the Rook moves
uh okay so he wants to play it that way
um sure sure yeah sure that's
possible
[Music]
it's really making this way harder than
it should
be is G4 a move I mean it does look like
a move yeah I think G4 is the move here
uh yeah let's go for that and now okay
the now the C5 square has become
available for the
queen uh so G4 might not be all that
impressive
yeah let's
[Music]
first let's first take away this C5
Square from the black queen and also put
even more pressure here and if he
captures on A2 which yeah okay he can do
that I will play Rook A1 attack the
queen and
then uh well then it's just game over uh
so very interested to see what he does
now yeah that Queen C5 could be very
annoying yeah and next maybe we go
G4 G4 he will play H6 then we go H4 and
we finally get rid of this
Knight yeah although uh I mean uh
whenever I played this opening it's very
very complicated to play it successfully
and Things become very very crazy and
you can't know all the lines uh you know
when I see okay you could have just done
this then I'm like yeah of course I
could have I I have no idea why I
didn't uh but it's uh yeah it's it's a
fun way to play against the Knight C6
Sicilian and unless your opponent really
knows how to uh I was planning on making
a video on that um I will show you
afterwards I don't know the exact line
but it's uh I mean it's pretty crazy
even with the absolute best defense if
your opponent knows it it's going to be
so hard for him to defend especially for
for like a Blitz game or even a rapid
game so it's um yeah really yeah of
course he goes for that he stops
G4 uh as he
should but now now the real question
emerges how does he defend against Queen
to
C4 yeah I'm kind of thinking maybe I
could have played that already but yeah
he does have Queen D5 then if I go Queen
C4
uh yeah that's very
unfortunate
H yes so I have to prepare it
first
now Queen D5 is actually impossible
Queen D5 is actually
impossible but uh it's not impossible
it's only impossible if my queen is uh
defended on C4 because then I could have
the in between
move
oh yeah Queen F5 is nice I don't have to
play that I could also play this this is
very
nice uh but then the Rook on B1 is
hanging yeah so I have to play Rook D1
first whatever I
do
yeah uh or or i' blunder it the the game
here but yeah now he does have to be
careful Queen C4 will end the the game
and
also yeah okay now he's
uh and okay the Knight is defended now
huh but now I can just kick away the
queen and that's it yeah that's pretty
much game Knight H4 ends the game
there's no Square from where the the
queen can tend to the Knight on
F6
uh yeah there okay there's Queen F4 but
then G3 I don't think that's going to
happen yeah it's remarkable how how much
time I'm actually spending here it's
very hard to calculate this maybe not
for you guys that are watching because
every time I play everyone in the
comments just says that they see
everything uh but it's I'm actually very
happy about that because when I started
this channel uh I was much stronger than
my audience but now it appears my my
audience is much much stronger than me
which makes me very
happy so yeah I don't think there's a
move here anymore yeah okay you can play
that uh but it's not going to help yeah
just a nice Rook cap person on D7 and
game
over uh or not yeah did
we
H yeah I forgot wow yeah it's always
possible
to to blunder a bit
more
h
can I play F3 here he captures yeah he
can't uh yeah I'm going to play F3
here
wow actually very
nice and once he captures I'm going to
play G3 and then I capture on
F6 very scary very scary stuff
here CU then once the queen moves and
there really aren't all that many great
squares for the
queen uh then we play Knight captures on
F7 attack the rook and threaten all
sorts of nasty discoveries and that
should be enough for us to win the game
maybe not with 53 seconds but
uh yeah should be should be okay if he
doesn't just ignore me but even if play
something like this then I can just play
like Rook captures here should be
fine yeah but what if he plays this yeah
still doesn't
matter or does it yeah if he plays this
I have to play Rook E7 first good to
know yeah on this I capture on this Rook
e s on on cap yeah there's I
mean un captures
G3 what else what else does he
have probably going to play something
tricky that I haven't uh thought of like
maybe no he's going to Capt Ro G3 have
to play without wasting too much
time
could actually play Rook captures on D6
now yeah also not not
terrible would even be great
yeah
H yeah Rook captures on D6 yeah that's
what I
missed yeah but uh I I've gotten so long
on time that it was bound to
happen but okay maybe he also misses
something
okay so he he will play that I don't
know
why he probably just missed r captur on
D6 or I missed something that's wrong
with Rook captur on
D6 uh because he was up a rook there he
he could have just given it
back all right so 48 seconds
now uh it would be very hard for me to
imagine not winning this but you never
know now that I've said it during the
video it's probably going to happen uh
as you know that that's how how it
usually goes but uh we'll see I mean I
mean there's there's really not much to
to mess up here but we be will be very
interesting going through this game uh
to see what we could have done
better yeah I don't know why he didn't
play Rook captur on D6
there was definitely definitely a
move maybe he's questioning that
now Mr Killer Mr Killer you had
it I think
so
yeah but it's uh I know I know what's
going to happen we're going to analyze
the game afterwards and I'm going to
find a mve that all of you saw uh and
it's just I mean okay this is not
winning on the
spot um yeah he has to play that oh we
can just take here it's not a problem we
can even okay so he doesn't even want to
take the
queen
um
there we go there we
go uh okay so he still he still doesn't
want it
uh yeah 20 seconds okay you don't want
it you don't have to there we go can
also play like
this all
right uh very nicely done Mr Killer I
believe you had me wow only 34 moves it
really felt like it was much more more
uh but yeah let's uh like from this
point on captures captures C4 okay uh D5
and all already this is quite
advantageous for me uh the engine gives
like a plus two two 2.5 yeah okay we
played everything correctly here Rook E1
Bishop
A3 okay so Queen D4 perhaps a little bit
better but yeah even Bishop captures on
E7 okay I played everything precisely
and I have no idea what went wrong there
uh ah okay so after Rook to d8 not Rook
B1 the immediate Queen to C4 and there's
no defense against mate yeah so I knew
there was a there was a killer killer
move here against Mr Killer
777 uh but and I found it I just found
it a few moves too late so okay here B6
again Queen C4 so I've been missing
queen C4 for quite a
while and uh yeah after Knight
H4 uh yeah this is all still winning oh
and now I play F3 so ah so here after
this Rook E7 that's the key move yeah
now after
F3 uh it's
actually yeah just Rook captures on D6
and he's a little bit better yeah we
have to go into this end game and he
will be better in that end game as he
he's up a pawn and he will be the one
pushing for the win here so there you
have it uh not not the best execution
but we got a winning position and we
missed that Queen to C4 maneuver very
early on uh but uh you know if you guys
uh want to try this out it's very very
possible that you will get a position
like this uh yeah don't miss this uh
yeah it's it says it's forc mate in 14
uh but probably if I played it you know
my opponent would have resigned right
away uh but yeah once again hope you
guys enjoyed it very nice Saturday rapid
game okay so here was two games because
in my previous game my opponent
blundered very quick quickly uh but yeah
hope you enjoyed that bit of uh some
thought process from a low lowlevel
rated player uh hope you enjoyed it and
I I will see you guys soon uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day